on arrivait à paris c'était
le rêve de gamin qui se réalise est ce
que moi avant de venir à paris j'étais
serveurs et je me souviendrai toute ma
vie de deux gars qui venait tous les
jours boire des cafés vous avez 50 60
piges et il n'arrêtait pas de me dire oh
[ __ ] si je pouvais repartir en arrière
j'ai réalisé mes rêves
si j'avais su j'adorerais revenir à mes
20 ans et en les regardant je me suis
dit un jour [ __ ] je suis obligé de le
faire parce que j'ai pas envie de me
retrouver dans trente piges 2 à ce même
comptoir avec un café en train de dire
[ __ ] mais si j'avais su j'aurais bossa
et gad elmaleh ben j'y étais j'ai bossé
avec gad elmaleh donc je suis assez fier
de ça l'arrivée à paris elle est
violente parce que la gare est très
bizarre lagarde saint-émilion c'est un
trottoir il ya un panneau et marquise
saint-émilion la gare de paris à des
vélos en bois pour gérer ton téléphone
des bars à jus on dirait un club med gym
voilà donc tu es un peu perdus pour
trouver un appartement il faut au
minimum 5 ans pourquoi on trouve un toit
donc tu vie j'ai de la famille rentrait
très longtemps avant de trouver ton chez
toi et une fois que tu trouves ton chez
toi c'est un placard voilà avec un
ascenseur pour les animaux domestiques
parce que tu rentres qu'à une personne
c'est la première fois que je vise un
ascenseur ou tu prends l'ascenseur comme
ça l appartement c'était compliqué parce
que moi j'étais en alternance je venais
d'avoir un diplôme
j'avais un petit chômage de 327 euros
par mois
j'étais étudiant dans un cours de
théâtre donc en fait il m'a regardé
comme un videur hat a vraiment cru que
tu as vraiment culte aller visiter un
gars partent et star est
[Musique]
ma première fois au cours simon c'était
très chaud doux très très chaude déjà tu
es à paris en plus dans un cours de
théâtre qui est très connu
donc j'arrive très intimidé je tombe sur
un prof qui me dit vous venez pourquoi
gilbert j'aimerais m'inscrire
il ya des auditions à 17h présenter
quelque chose je dis j'ai rien du tout
une des mails importe quoi un programme
de télé un article de journal est dans
le court il ya un espèce de oulu les
élèves répètent et il ya des cours de
déclamation et moi je connaissais pas
fais-tu rentrer des gens ont écrit des
trucs du genre je vois la croix de voix
de blois on est mardi les 16 heures je
suis complètement intimider et je
regarde lui donne ses cours simon ou
sainte-anne tu vois elle était un délire
tu dis vraiment les gens sont normaux là
et c'est ouf parce que j'ai passé une
audition que j'ai récité un programme de
télé c'est joséphine ange gardien je
m'en souviens toute ma vie et j'ai fait
le synopsis quoi j'avais appris avec
quatre lits et le gars me dit c'est nul
on est 30
il ya 30 personnes qui te regardes tu es
vraiment intimidés au possible et en
sortant une prend dans son bureau il me
dit bon c'était de la merde mais vous
avez quelque chose
revenez demain et j'ai fait trois ans
[Musique]
première scène ouverte je monte sur
scène j'ai un sketch avec une bouteille
de vin parce que je parle de
saint-émilion mon village natal et je
sais pas pourquoi je ne m'en sers pas
comme s'il y avait un piano mais j'en
jouais pas sur scène
là j'ai une bouteille de vin que je
tiens pendant 3 minutes et j'en parle
jamais donc les gens se disent le gars
est celle où alcoolique et je fais mon
sketch et des gens qui sont alignés sur
des tables en train de dîner ils sont
une centaine
et ça prend ça va prendre un focus sur
scène devant un public qui m'attend pas
qui en a rien à [ __ ] qui découvre des
nouveaux talents et je fais trois
minutes sari tue plus dans ma vie
d'avant août une tête épaules qui disent
max tu devrais faire de l'humour
là c'est vraiment un métier quoi je
parle beaucoup de la différence entre
paris et les parisiens et les
provinciaux mais là pour ce coup là
cette première scène ouverte
j'ai été reçu avec un accueil hyper
chaleureux j'étais personne j'étais très
intimidée j'avais peur je savais pas si
on allait me prendre parce que tu viens
de présenter et on ne prend on dit à la
semaine prochaine ya pas de place ce
soir
et là elle me met sur la liste et j'ai
un accueil qui est un peu qui galvanise
en fait je me dis [ __ ] tu vois je suis
en sécurité dans un cocon où je sais que
je vais me chier dessus pendant cinq
minutes mais les gens sont là pour te
mettre un petit peu ans et cuba donc
accueil très cool
et puis le public parisien quoi ma
première scène ouverte là bas ça
cartonne moi je me dis c'est bon c'est
bon normalement
derrière on a un molière bon on va la
voir le molière on est dessus qu'ils
étaient en train de bosser dessus